I have to tell you until seeing this
film I didn't even know I needed this
duo in my life you guys are so good
together
thank you oh it's cool right who will
say that we will be together one day I
know I know and so I want more of this
uh Javier you told us uh last month that
you give your singing a 5 out of 10 on a
good day which I disagree with Sean how
do you Ray Javier singing in this he's
he's for for someone who's never sang in
their life
he's a he's an 8.9 out of 10. oh my God
look at that
in person Jesus no I don't think people
understand how difficult the songs were
that he was singing they were difficult
you know it's not great man heavier that
must have made your day
go after that okay okay
well now I'm gonna ask you Sean this is
obviously your feature film debut Javier
how did he do in this
well let me tell you what what he's
doing is not easy because he has to
bring the soul of a of uh of a crocodile
into the singing and
he's sweet he's
uh commanding his farm his loving tender
he has everything his voice that's why
he is who he is and it's a pleasure to
listen here it helps when you have
amazing CGI artist working on your
facial expression but honestly when Lyle
was upset I was upset I was like me too
did you feel the same way I totally did
it was interesting too I know that they
had cameras in there as I was like
shooting and I don't know how much but
apparently they were using similar like
eye movements and stuff from me put it
into Lyle so I was like oh I was
wondering at times I was like that's
really cool yeah I know it was it was
really effective um Sean I love that
you're always so open and honest with
your fans especially when it comes to
prioritizing your mental health what was
this whole experience like for you what
did this film bring to your life
it just it's just something so new for
me I think yeah you know you don't I
mean especially like you don't realize
how special voicing an animated
character is until you do it I mean the
first time I finally saw a clip back and
it was Lyle and my voice was coming
through this crocodile's mouth it was
like pretty surreal it was like I was
pretty struck by it
um it was magical it was difficult it
wasn't a super easy process either it
was actually super challenging and I
just I loved it honestly
that's amazing are you going to want to
do more acting roles what do you think
do this kind of you get the acting bug I
I definitely I definitely will I
definitely think next time maybe you'll
see my face in front of the camera but
for sure
have you ever saw you smiling I really
hope we can share that that would be
great I would love to you guys need to
do like a buddy cop film now or
something I'll watch anything you guys
together
we are we are here for higher we're
ready
uh Javier when it when you look at a
character like Lyle and just this whole
film it's such a beautiful story uh why
were you excited to be a part of this
because it's really out of my comfort
zone and I was doing things I never
thought I was going to do and basically
I was just following others my kids told
me you have to make this movie and I
said but
I don't sing and dance I don't care you
have to go out there and sing and dance
with a crocodile in New York dad oh I
did it and then I found myself in front
of a crocodile singing and dancing and I
was like oh my God but I I loved every
second of it and I loved uh Josh and
Will the directors great time doing it
there's always hard work in every movie
you do and there was hard work and some
days worked up especially the the
dancing for me but uh but I loved it you
nailed it honestly the whole movie uh
was so well done uh congratulations you
guys so nice getting to talk to both of
you